a menos de una semana después de reabrir
la llave del gasoducto nord stream 1
gazprom volverá a cerrarlo parcialmente
el gigante del gas ruso anunció en su
cuenta telegram que a partir de
miércoles las entregas de gas a europa
serán reducidas a la mitad la capacidad
productiva de la estación de comprensión
de puerto vaya pasará a 33 millones de
metros cúbicos diarios el 27 de julio a
las 4 gmt este flujo representa sólo el
20 por ciento de su capacidad
el kremlin justificó esta nueva
reducción en la necesidad de
mantenimiento de una de las dos últimas
turbinas en funcionamiento la
explicación que berlín rechazó afirmando
que no veía ninguna razón técnica de su
lado el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
es de lenski afirmó que rusia está
librando una guerra abierta del gas
contra europa y pidió represalias de
parte de la unión europea acaso es
santarsiero para el chantaje del gas a
europa que no hace más que empeorar cada
mes lo necesita un estado terrorista
para empeorar la vida de todos los
europeos y esto puede verse como un
incentivo para que el octavo paquete de
sanciones de la unión europea sea
significativamente más fuerte que él
séptimo recientemente probado
desde el principio de la guerra el
presidente ruso vladimir putin denuncia
las sanciones europeas y advirtió este
mes de que podrían provocar un aumento
catastrófico de los precios de la
energía para los consumidores de todo el
mundo europa importa de rusia alrededor
del 40% de su gas y por eso la comisión
europea pide a sus estados miembros que
hagan todo lo posible para reducir su
consumo anticipando un posible corte
neto del grifo de nord stream uno en el
futuro invierno